This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。真人保证。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客“2%”中，我将剖析我们在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中保持心理坚韧、健身和建立韧性的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的自己。收听“2%”。就是数字的2。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约定时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他不会轻易逃脱惩罚的。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。听女朋友的话。相信我，宝贝。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。在“回顾过去”播客中。对于1979年来说，对我来说这是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会选择一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说更重要了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听“回顾过去”。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？您正在收听由您最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖姆斯主持的“艰难学习”。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行在任何其他地方都真的不安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是在与一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套铠甲。这向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听并学习“艰难学习”。
Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show of our 20s. Welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you get back for another episode as we, of course, break down the psychology of our 20s. You know, I truly believe that this decade is such a sacred time for every single one of us.
大家好，欢迎回到“你二十岁的心理学”，这是一个探讨我们二十岁时的一些重大生活变化和转变及其对我们心理学意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到我们的二十岁节目。欢迎回到播客，新听友，老听友，无论你在世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能回来收听另一集，当然，我们要剖析二十岁的心理学。你知道，我真的相信这个十年对我们每个人来说都是一个神圣的时期。
There is something kind of magical about being this young and chaotic, but also so focused on the future, gaining self-awareness, wanting to get the most out of life's experiences, kind of grown up, kind of still young, kind of still naive, kind of still excited. There's just so much to learn. So much to learn, especially about ourselves and there's these huge life-changing moments of growth and wonder and joy, and also these huge relationships. A big part of this whole experience of this decade, something that really makes and breaks our years and our months as 20-something-year-olds, is who we choose to date, who we fall for,
在如此年轻和混乱的同时又如此专注于未来、获得自我觉察、想要充分利用生活中的经历、有点像成年人、有点仍然年轻、有点仍然天真、有点仍然兴奋，这种感觉有一种神奇的魔力。有太多东西要学了。有太多东西要学，尤其是关于我们自己的，并且有着这些巨大的改变人生的成长、惊奇和喜悦的时刻，还有这些巨大的关系。整个十年经历的很大一部分，真正造就或毁掉我们二十几岁时的年份和月份的因素，是我们选择和谁约会，我们为谁倾心，
who we spend our time with, you know, romantically, whether that's in a committed sense or not, the people that we pursue. I think that if you ask most of us in this decade, what is one of the things that you think the most about or which has the biggest impact on your experiences and your mood and so much else, it would be love and it would be relationships and it would be dating. And it's honestly such a formative part of these years, but not all relationships are meant to be. and they're not always beneficial to this like journey of discovery that we've got going on in our 20s and not always who we need. Sometimes being in love and having fun just isn't enough, especially when there are some pretty huge signs that this relationship might not be going anywhere.
我们把时间花在谁身上，你知道的，在浪漫意义上，无论是在承诺的意义上还是没有，我们追求的人。我想，如果你在这个十年里问我们大多数人，你认为你最常想到的是什么事情之一，或者对你的经历、你的情绪以及其他许多事情产生最大影响的是什么，那就是爱，那就是人际关系，那就是约会。老实说，这是这些年里非常具有形成性的一部分，但并非所有关系都是命中注定的，它们并不总是对我们在二十岁时正在进行的这种探索之旅有益，也并不总是我们所需要的。有时，恋爱和玩乐是不够的，尤其是当有一些相当巨大的迹象表明这段关系可能无疾而终时。
It might be costing you a lot more than you thought it would be. It might actually be jeopardizing some of the experiences that you have in this period of life or jeopardizing, part of your identity or your personhood in general. And I think one of the big regrets that a lot of people have, or something that we think that we're going to regret, we fear is being in our late 20s, early 30s and realizing that we ignored red flags in our relationship or we continue to pursue people who weren't good for us and we really should have been alone and we really should have been with somebody better. And that's what I want to talk about today. What are the red flags specifically for relationships in our 20s that we need to look out for.
它可能比你想象的要付出更多的代价。它实际上可能会危及你在这一人生阶段的一些经历，或者危及你的部分身份或你的整体个性。我认为很多人都有的一个大遗憾，或者我们认为我们会后悔的、我们害怕的事情，就是在我们二十岁后期、三十岁早期时，意识到我们忽视了我们关系中的危险信号，或者我们继续追求那些对我们不好的人，而我们本该独自一人，本该和更好的人在一起。这就是我今天要谈论的。具体来说，我们需要注意的二十岁时人际关系的危险信号是什么。
What are the warning signs that something is off in a relationship or about a person? You know, I think we all understand what red flags are. They are essentially these things that should cause us to break things off with somebody. And there are a lot of red flags that are pretty universal. If they're jealous, if they treat you poorly, if they don't communicate or support you, if they love bum you, if they're narcissistic, these are really true no matter. where you are, your gender, and most specifically your age. But there are some red flags that I think are specifically valuable to be aware of during this decade. They're a bit more nuanced. They're a bit more
人际关系中或某个人身上出现问题时的警告信号是什么？你知道，我想我们都明白什么是危险信号。它们本质上是应该促使我们与某人断绝关系的事情。有很多危险信号是相当普遍的。如果他们嫉妒，如果他们对你不好，如果他们不沟通或不支持你，如果他们进行“轰炸式示爱”，如果他们是自恋狂，无论你在哪里、你的性别是什么、尤其是你的年龄是什么，这些都是真的。但有一些危险信号，我认为在这个十年里了解它们尤其有价值。它们更微妙一些。它们更多的是
specific to the life stage and the period that we're in and the experiences that we're having. And I think my biggest guiding philosophy that I had when thinking about these five big red flags was that the relationship with the right person during this decade can really elevate the experiences that you're having in your 20s, but with the wrong person, you are much better experiencing everything by yourself or with your friends or accompanied by family or platonic love than spending these years hoping somebody's going to change with the wrong person, in the wrong relationship. There is, I think, a very fine line and an important line between wanting to experience love,
特定于我们所处的人生阶段和时期以及我们正在经历的经历。我想我在思考这五个大危险信号时最大的指导哲学是：在这个十年里与对的人建立关系真的可以提升你在二十岁时的经历，但与错的人在一起，你最好独自经历一切，或者和你的朋友在一起，或者有家人或柏拉图式爱情的陪伴，而不是把这些年花在希望某人会改变、与错的人在一起、处于一段错误的关系中。我认为，想要体验爱与
but then also knowing that you would benefit from being sick. single. And that's what I want to talk about today. What are the red flags that we should look out for? What are the situations that we don't want to get stuck in? What are some of the things that we might realize will inevitably cost us so that we will inevitably regret about the relationships that we have in our 20s? We have so much to cover. So without further ado, my lovely listeners, let's get into it. Let's start this off strong. If there was just one red flag on this list, and none other, no other red flags, personally, this would be my number, my number one as it relates to our 20s. So our number one red flag, if they hold you back from having experiences, especially the
同时又知道自己会从单身中受益，这两者之间有一条非常微妙且重要的界限。这就是我今天要谈论的。我们需要注意的危险信号是什么？我们不想陷入的困境是什么？我们可能会意识到不可避免地要付出代价的事情是什么，从而我们会不可避免地对我们在二十岁时的关系感到后悔？我们要讲的内容太多了。废话不多说，我可爱的听众们，让我们切入正题吧。让我们强势开局。如果这份清单上只有一个危险信号，别的什么都没有，没有其他危险信号，就我个人而言，这将是我的数字，这会是我关于我们二十岁的首要危险信号。所以我们的头号危险信号是，如果他们阻止你拥有经历，尤其是
kind of experiences that create memories that are going to last longer than that relationship, that is not the right relationship for you. Listen, everyone is in a different stage, but if you have big dreams of moving overseas or traveling for three months or starting your own business or solo hiking or whatever it is. Please, please, please, please, don't give that up for a relationship. A good relationship should allow you to be all of those things and more. You should feel secure enough in that connection and in the stability of your partnership to be an independent person because you don't get this time back.
那种创造出比那段关系更持久的记忆的经历，那绝对不是适合你的关系。听着，每个人都处于不同的阶段，但如果你有去海外搬迁或旅行三个月或创办自己的企业或独自徒步旅行的宏伟梦想，无论是什么。求求你，求求你，求求你，千万不要为了谈恋爱而放弃这些。一段好的关系应该允许你成为所有这些以及更多。你应该对那种联系和伴侣关系的稳定性感到足够安全，从而做一个独立的人，因为这段时间你是无法倒回的。
You might not get this opportunity again. You may never be where you are now. You may never be prepared to seek out this adventure and take that. at risk. And if you wait for when your partner is ready or you hold off because somebody you're dating doesn't want to go or doesn't want you to go, which is even worse. I'm telling you right now, you will regret that. And the reason that I know this is because there have been studies on this very thing. Saying no or not making a decision leads to so much more long-term regret than saying yes, even if by saying yes, you end up losing out on something else. Because that experience,
你可能不会再有这个机会了。你可能永远不会回到现在的状态。你可能永远没有准备好去寻找这场冒险并承担风险。如果你在等待伴侣准备好，或者因为你在约会的人不想去或不想你去而犹豫不决，那就更糟了。我现在就告诉你，你会后悔的。我知道这一点的原因是因为有关于这方面的研究。说不或不做出决定，比说“好”会带来更多长期的遗憾，即使通过说“好”，你最终可能会失去其他一些东西。因为那段经历，
those memories will make up for what it is that you might lose. They will last so much longer. They will be such a source of joy. And they will just be evidence that despite the barriers, despite everything telling you to stay with this person, to stay safe, to stay comfortable, you did it anyways. Some of the most enduring regrets that people have at the end of their life, and which they tell people who do studies on this,
那些记忆将弥补你可能失去的东西。它们会持续更长时间。它们将成为快乐的源泉。它们将成为一种证明，即尽管有重重阻碍，尽管一切都在告诉你留在这个人身边，保持安全，保持舒适，但你还是去做了。人们在生命结束时最大的遗憾之一，也是那些做这项研究的人告诉别人的事情，
they stem from actions not taken. And the right kind of love will accommodate your dreams. The worst kinds of love will restrict you, will want to keep you small. So when I first started dating my boyfriend, like three months in, I kind of sat him down and said basically, if I wasn't dating you, I wouldn't be in Australia. I had these plans that in six months' time, like at the end of the year, that I was going to move overseas. And I used to kind of always joke with people when we first met that it was like such terrible timing to meet somebody so wonderful to mean like the love of my life. Like, part of me was
它们源于未采取的行动。而正确的爱会容纳你的梦想。最糟糕的爱会限制你，会想把你缩小。所以当我开始和我男友约大约三个月的时候，我把他拉坐下来，基本上对他说，如果我不是在跟你约会，我现在就不会在澳大利亚。我有这样的计划：在六个月后，也就是年底的时候，我要搬到海外去。当我们刚见面时，我常常开玩笑说，遇到一个这么棒的人、遇到我一生的挚爱，时机实在是太糟糕了。就像，我的一部分
a bit like, oh my gosh, why didn't I meet him like a year earlier when everything was still up in the air? Why, you know, why did I meet him in two years time when I'd gone and done and done those things? And I did have a moment of being like, I don't want to give my dreams up for this guy who only three months ago was a stranger. And so I talked to him about it. I said, you know, I really want to live overseas. And I really, really like you. I don't know if I loved him at that point, but I was like, I really enjoy our relationship. But, you know, this is kind of a deal breaker for me. And you know what he said? He said, okay, let's make a timeline. If this is an experience that you want to have to live overseas for a year or two, let's make it happen. And if you want to go now, let's make it work. And that was a huge
有点像，天哪，为什么我没有在一年前一切都还悬而未决的时候遇到他呢？为什么，你知道，为什么我没有在我去过并做过那些事情两年后才遇到他呢？我确实有过一瞬间的想法，我不想为了这个三个月前还是个陌生人的家伙放弃我的梦想。所以我跟他谈了谈。我说，你知道，我真的很想去海外生活。而且我真的很喜欢你。我不知道那时我是不是爱他，但我想，我真的很享受我们的关系。但是，你知道，这对我来说有点像是原则问题。你知道他说什么吗？他说，好吧，我们定个时间表吧。如果这是你想拥有的在海外生活一两年的经历，我们让它发生。如果你现在就想走，我们让它行得通。这是一个巨大的
green flag. It was like a respect for the fact that my life existed beyond our relationship. And he really appreciated my dreams. And he appreciated my dreams not just for my life, but for my 20s. You know, I'm somebody who thinks about their 20s a lot and who thinks about getting the most out of this decade so much. And I think that I couldn't be with somebody who didn't appreciate what I wanted to experience in the life I wanted to live. So if someone doesn't respect those things, if they hold you back, if they make you feel insecure about doing the things that you want to do, if they don't want you to do them without them, I just think that that shouldn't impede your decision making and that you should be free to be a person before you are a partner,
绿灯。这就像是对我的生活超越了我们关系的尊重。他真的很感激我的梦想。他不仅为我的生活，也为我的二十岁感激我的梦想。你知道，我是一个经常思考自己的二十岁、非常想要充分利用这十年的人。我想我无法和一个不欣赏我想体验的生活、我想过的生活的人在一起。所以如果有人不尊重这些事情，如果他们阻碍你，如果你想做你想做的事却让他们让你感到不安全，如果他们不想让你在没有他们的情况下做这些事情，我只是觉得这不应该阻碍你的决策，在成为伴侣之前，你应该自由地成为一个人，
to have a life before you have a relationship. So, red flag number two, they are not the one if they are causing you intense emotional chaos. there is a really fine balance between someone who is exciting and exhilarating and someone who is going to absolutely destroy everything in your life, your self-esteem, your values, your self-confidence. And that can take a long time to repair. So there was a study in 2019 that examined this very thing. They examined romantic relationships in emerging adulthood. An emerging adulthood is this period between like 18 and 29.
在拥有恋爱关系之前拥有生活。所以，危险信号之二，如果他们给你带来剧烈的情绪混乱，他们就不是对的人。一个令人兴奋、令人振奋的人，和一个将彻底毁掉你生活中一切、你的自尊、你的价值观、你的自信的人之间，有着非常微妙的平衡。这可能需要很长时间才能修复。所以在2019年有一项研究正好考察了这一点。他们考察了成人初期浪漫关系。而成人初期是18岁到29岁之间的这段时期。
And what this research suggested was that romantic relationships, relationships during this period that are unpredictable, that are disruptive or distressing, they can actually cause significant changes in our mood, significant changes in our interest in life, they can reduce our positive emotions and they can reduce our sense of stable self-worth. And that impact doesn't disappear when we leave the relationship either. It can linger, sometimes for years. So let me explain what I mean by intense emotional chaos. And if you relate to any of these things, see it as a red flag.
而这项研究所暗示的是，浪漫关系、这一时期的关系如果不可预测、具有破坏性或令人痛苦，实际上会对我们的情绪造成重大改变，对我们对生活的兴趣造成重大改变，它们会减少我们的积极情绪，并减少我们对稳定自我价值感。而且这种影响在我们离开这段关系后也不会消失。它可能会挥之不去，有时甚至持续数年。让我解释一下我所说的剧烈情绪混乱是什么意思。如果你与以下任何事情产生共鸣，请将其视为危险信号。
So feeling good about the relationship one day and then terrible the next without any explanation as to why, never knowing what to expect from the other person. Your emotions are out of control when it comes to this person or your relationship, crying over this person in your relationship, sometimes without any given reason, feeling nauseous or anxious about the future, not feeling like yourself. if your friends notice that you've changed or you're less in touch with yourself or you're upset, feeling the need to kind of completely explode your life because of them. That is the intense emotional chaos that I'm talking about.
所以，有一天对这段关系感觉很好，第二天又感觉糟透了，没有任何理由解释为什么，永远不知道对另一个人有什么期望。当涉及到这个人或你的关系时，你的情绪失控了，为这个人和这段关系哭泣，有时没有任何给定的理由，对未来感到恶心或焦虑，感觉不像是自己。如果你的朋友注意到你变了，或者你对自己的联系变少了，或者你很难过，感觉因为他们而需要彻底引爆你的生活。这就是我所说的剧烈情绪混乱。
There are a few kinds of relationships that I think create this reaction. For starters, you know, relationships with people who are just simply manipulative or breadcrumbing you or who, you know, aren't right for you and in our deepest of hearts, we know that, that often elicits this reaction. but the biggest one that is very so uniquely 20-something is situationhips. These half-baked pseudo-relationships that leave you feeling uneasy and unsure of what actually to expect, unsure of what's actually going on and very convoluted. Situationhips by nature are chaotic because whilst you're in them, they neither have a future
我认为有几种关系会产生这种反应。首先，你知道，与那些单纯操纵你、给你“抛出面包屑”的人的关系，或者那些对你不合适、我们内心深处也知道这一点的人的关系，往往会引发这种反应。但最大的一种、非常独特地属于二十多岁人群的是“Situationship”（暧昧不清的非正式关系）。这些半生不熟的伪关系让你感到不安，不确定到底该有什么期待，不确定到底发生了什么，而且非常错综复杂。暧昧关系本质上是混乱的，因为当你在其中时，它们既没有未来
or an end. So they are constantly suspended in this emotional limit. limbo. And I think whilst our natural instinct is to bond and attach to this person because we are connecting with them, we are building memories with them, we are sharing time with them, the lack of a label or exclusivity creates this very logical and rational understanding that we shouldn't be doing that. But our emotional and our biological urge is doing so anyways. So basically what I'm saying is that you end up getting attached whether you want to or not. these situations can be so intense.
也没有终点。所以它们不断地悬置在这种情感的炼狱中。而且我认为，虽然我们的本能是与这个人建立纽带和依恋，因为我们在与他们建立联系，我们在与他们建立记忆，我们在与他们分享时间，但缺乏标签或排他性会产生一种非常合乎逻辑和理性的理解，即我们不应该这样做。但我们的情感和生物学冲动无论如何都在这样做。所以基本上我想说的是，无论你愿不愿意，你最终都会产生依恋。这些情况可以如此激烈。
I do really feel for anyone who was going through this at the moment. Back in like 2021, I was in this like six-month relationship with this guy after the end of my first big long-term relationship. And it was like a complete roller coaster and it was a complete disaster. And throughout the experience, I, it was a state of emotional chaos. I lost a big part of myself. I lost friends. And I lost my sense of self-respect. and to be honest, I think I lost a bit of my healthy perspective on love.
我真的很同情目前正在经历这一经历的任何人。大约在2021年，在我的第一段重大长期关系结束后，我和这个家伙维持了大约六个月的这种关系。这就像是一场完全的过山车，完全是一场灾难。在整个经历中，我，它处于一种情绪混乱的状态。我失去了很大一部分自我。我失去了朋友。我失去了自尊心。说实话，我想我失去了一些对爱的健康看法。
And it took a while to recover. It took a while to unlearn what I had implicitly learned about myself and about others because of that situation. Nowadays, I definitely value what I went through because it taught me things about myself that I never would have learned, but I would have preferred to learn them in a different way rather than going through that. And the biggest red flag for me should have been the emotional chaos I was
这花了我好一段时间才恢复过来。我花了好久才打破那种因为那段经历而在潜意识里对自己和他人产生的错误认知。如今，我绝对珍惜这段经历，因为它让我懂得了关于自己的很多道理，这些是我本来永远不会学到的，但我宁愿用别的方式去学懂，而不是经历这一切。对我来说，最明显的警示信号本该是我当时感受到的情感混乱。
experiencing at the beginning. But because I was in such a self-destructive place, and I'll be the first to admit it, the anxiety, the ups and downs, the jitters, that, you know, that was my intuition telling me to break it off, but those jitters, those experiences, this emotion, it felt fun and it felt exciting, and I didn't know how to identify what I was going through. Maybe it's a rite of passage. I don't know maybe a lot of people you have to have a relationship like this in your 20s. It seems like a lot of us have, but I also think save the suffering, save the misery, save yourself the time and the inevitable explosion three months, six months later, and try and notice those feelings when they first occur.
在刚开始的时候。但因为我当时正处于一种自我毁灭的状态，我承认这一点，那种焦虑、起伏不定、心神不宁，你知道的，那是我的直觉在告诉我该分手了，但那些焦虑、那些经历、这种情绪，感觉很有趣也很刺激，我当时根本不知道该如何识别我正在经历的事情。也许这是一场成礼。我不知道，也许很多人在20多岁时都得经历这样一段感情。似乎我们很多人都有过，但我也在想，省省那些痛苦、悲惨、省去你的时间和三六个月后不可避免的爆发，试着在那些感觉第一次出现时就去注意它们。
So, Red Flag, number three, a little bit different from that last one. They don't celebrate you or encourage you. Now this is problematic to me for quite a few reasons. Number one, quite frankly, you just deserve someone who thinks you are incredible. And I think that being celebratory and encouraging somebody is just part of being a good partner. So it kind of shows that they aren't that. And number two, it is part of a healthy partnership. And it shows their commitment to your growth, which is also a great green flag.
所以，第三个警示信号，和上一个有点不同。他们不为你庆祝，也不鼓励你。这让我觉得很有问题，原因有很多。第一，坦白说，你值得拥有一个认为你非常了不起的人。我认为懂得庆祝和鼓励某人，本来就是成为一个好伴侣的一部分。所以这在某种程度上表明他们并非如此。第二，这也是健康伴侣关系的一部分。这表明他们致力于你的成长，这也是一个很好的积极信号。
Number three, if they aren't celebrating you now, don't expect that to change in the future. so I always say how the relationship begins, it's how it ends. If it has begun with a complete deficit in them feeling proud of you or them wanting to express happiness for you, that's not going to change. And number four, which is similar to number two, actually comes down to a theory known as the Michelangelo theory, which states that our close partners sculpt us into hopefully becoming the best versions of ourselves by implicitly promoting and encouraging our best traits and inhibiting the things that hold us back. The reason that it's called the Michelangelo phenomena is after the artist and the sculptor who would make these beautiful creations from marble.
第三，如果他们现在不为你庆祝，就不要指望未来会有所改变。所以我总是说，一段感情如何开始，就会如何结束。如果它的开始就伴随着他们对你感到骄傲的完全缺失，或者他们不愿为你表达快乐，那这是不会改变的。第四点，其实类似于第二点，归结为一个被称为米开朗琪罗效应的理论，该理论指出，我们亲密的伴侣会塑造我们，让我们通过潜意识地推广和鼓励我们最好的特质、抑制那些阻碍我们前进的事物，从而希望我们成为最好的自己。之所以被称为米开朗琪罗现象，是因为这位艺术家和雕塑家曾用大理石创造出这些美丽的杰作。
And that is what a good partner can do to you. It's not that they are like intentionally chipping away and trying to make you a better person or make you into the version of you that they like. It's more that the right person encourages the things. that you really like about yourself and helps you become the version of you that you have chosen to become or who is within you. One way that they do that is through encouragement and celebration, which as the theory would suggest, pushes us towards our ideal selves. We obviously care about our partner's opinions and we trust what they say and what they think. And if they are the ones
而这就是一个好伴侣对你所能做到的。并不是说他们像是有意地在雕琢，试图让你成为一个更好的人，或者让你变成他们喜欢的那个版本的你。更准确地说，对的人会鼓励那些你自己真正喜欢的东西，并帮助你成为你选择成为的那个版本，或是那个本就存在于你内心的自己。他们做到这一点的方式之一就是通过鼓励和庆祝，正如该理论所暗示的那样，这会推动我们走向理想的自我。我们显然很在乎伴侣的看法，我们信任他们所说和所想的。如果他们是那种人
who are like, yeah, that was a really great job that you went to the gym today. We feel really great when they say that or if they encourage us to go back to school or if they encourage us to pursue our dreams, that is quite motivating. And if your partner is not doing that, especially now, especially in your 20s, I think that that is something that isn't going to change and perhaps it's preventing you from living up to your potential. And you know, also, I just think that naturally if you love somebody, if you care about them, you want, you do care about their future. And, and you do care about their goals and their pursuits, and you do want them to improve the way that they see fit. I think we often think about our goals and our dreams as quite a solitary affair,
他们会说：“嘿，你今天去健身房表现得真棒。”当他们这么说的时候，我们会感觉非常棒；或者如果他们鼓励我们重返校园，或者鼓励我们去追求梦想，这相当具有激励作用。如果你的伴侣没有这么做，尤其是在现在，尤其是在你20多岁的时候，我认为这是不会改变的，也许它正在阻碍你发挥潜能。而且你知道，我也认为，自然而然地，如果你爱一个人，如果你在乎他们，你确实会关心他们的未来。并且，你也确实会关心他们的目标和追求，并且你确实希望他们按照他们认为合适的方式不断进步。我认为我们经常把我们的目标和梦想看作是一件相当孤独的事情，
especially during this decade when we're just getting started. You know, it all comes down to our discipline and our commitment and our intelligence and our creativity and the hours that we are putting into something. But this theory really suggests that the opposite is true, that actually it does take a village, and it's the people closest to us who have of the biggest influence on whether we succeed in our dreams or whether we don't. There's also additional research that shows that having an equally motivated partner who encourages you and celebrates you, but also is equally productive and equally pursuing a sense of satisfaction and fulfillment in their lives will help you be a better person.
尤其是在我们刚刚起步的这十年里。你知道，这一切都归结于我们的纪律、承诺、智慧、创造力，以及我们投入到某件事情上的时间。但这个理论真正表明的是事实恰恰相反，实际上这确实需要大家的共同努力，正是那些离我们最近的人，对我们能否实现梦想有着最大的影响。还有其他研究表明，拥有一个同样有动力、鼓励你、庆祝你，同时也同样高效、在生活中同样在追求满足感和成就感的伴侣，会帮助你成为一个更好的人。
It's called social contagion. That's what we call it in psychology. You probably heard the quote. You know, you are the product. of the five people closest to you, and that's what this idea of social contagion reflects, your partner is definitely one of those five, right? And the older we get, the further we get into our 20s and even our 30s and our 40s, they normally become the number one.
这叫做社会传染。这是我们在心理学中对它的称呼。你可能听过这句话。你知道，你就是你身边最亲密的五个人的产物，而这就是社会传染这个概念所反映的，你的伴侣绝对是这五个人之一，对吧？而且我们年龄越大，步入20多岁甚至30多岁、40多岁，他们通常就会成为第一位。
So if they aren't in your corner, if you have a big win at work and they brush past it, if you, like, set a PR at the gym and it's not something that they care about or they're even interested in, sometimes their disinterest can actually work as a form of negative reinforcement and it can discourage you from continuing to pursue your goals. You know, the opposite of the Michelangelo phenomenon is actually the blueberry phenomena. And what the blueberry theory basically says is that interdependent people bring out the worst in each other because when one person is doing poorly or failing or struggling, they bring the other person down with them. You know, it's kind of that where the name comes from is having like a punnet of blueberries or strawberries. And if you've
所以，如果他们不支持你，如果你在工作上取得了重大胜利而他们却轻描淡写地一带而过，如果你在健身房创造了个人最佳纪录而这根本不是他们关心的事，甚至不是他们感兴趣的事，有时他们的冷淡实际上会起到一种负面强化的作用，并且会阻止你继续追求自己的目标。你知道，米开朗琪罗现象的对立面其实是蓝莓现象。蓝莓理论基本上是说，相互依赖的人会把彼此最好的一面消磨掉，因为当一个人表现不佳、失败或苦苦挣扎时，他们会把另一个人也一同拉入谷底。你知道，这个名字的由来有点像是有一篮蓝莓或草莓。如果你
ever had like one blueberry go bad in the punnet, like quickly the whole, the rest of the blueberries become rotten. And that is what this theory is saying is basically like, if you are with a partner who does not encourage you or celebrate you or who does not want you to succeed, it's not that they're rotten, but, you know, their values are contagious and might end up spoiling your own goals. And I know it's very easy to see dating in our 20s as maybe lower stakes, especially early in our 20s, because we have a lot of time to find the one and to explore and to get your heartbroken and whatever that may be. But really don't compromise on this one factor. If you're going to be in a long-term committed relationship with somebody, maybe you won't, but if you're going
篮子里曾经有一个蓝莓坏掉了，很快整个篮子里剩下的蓝莓也都会腐烂。这就是这个理论所表达的意思，基本上就是，如果你和一个不鼓励你、不为你庆祝、也不希望你成功的人在一起，并不是说他们腐烂了，而是你知道，他们的价值观具有传染性，最终可能会毁了你自己的目标。我知道，把20多岁的约会看作是风险较低的事情非常容易，尤其是在20多岁刚开始的时候，因为我们有很多时间去寻找真爱、去探索、去经历心碎，无论那可能是什么。但千万不要在这个因素上妥协。如果你要和某人建立长期的承诺关系，也许你不会，但如果你要
to, they better think that you are fantastic and they better be in your corner for everything that you do, especially, especially during such a formative decade for your identity and in which we are growing our own self-worth. We want to build the skills and the community to succeed in whatever it is we're doing. So quick recap of our red flags so far. Number one, if they hold you back from having important experiences, red flag. If they're creating emotional chaos, red flag. And finally, if they don't celebrate or encourage you, huge red flag. We have two final. points to talk about today, the red flags for the relationships that we have in our 20s.
建立这种关系，他们最好认为你棒极了，并且在你做的每一件事上都支持你，尤其是在塑造你自我价值的关键十年里，在这个十年里，我们正在建立自己的自我价值。我们希望培养技能和社群，以便在我们所做的任何事情中取得成功。所以快速回顾一下我们目前的警示信号。第一，如果他们阻碍你获得重要的经历，这是个警示信号。如果他们制造情感混乱，这是个警示信号。最后，如果他们不为你庆祝或鼓励你，这是一个巨大的警示信号。今天我们还有最后两个要讨论的重点，即我们在20多岁时经历的感情中的警示信号。
And we're going to return to those plus a few maybe bonus signs, bonus flags, after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the
在这段简短的广告之后，我们将回到这些话题以及一些额外的迹象和额外的信号。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，心理韧性、健身和建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，看透那些主导了
wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap
健康行业的既不切实际又过于复杂的伪科学。“我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们搞错了。”我们在世界上恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《TWO%》。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击
Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick you here.
小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back At It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会邀请你来到这里，
unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so.
剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何挺过那段时光的。包括最近一集邀请了马克·拉蒙特·希尔，大谈80年代的可卡因。需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时都可以聊可卡因，只是想让你们知道。我是说，到目前为止，马克，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集，所以我开始看出这里有一条主线了。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在台面上，所以。
Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black. people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests.
谢谢你把那句话说完。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back At It》。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将把我在心理健康领域十多年的经验以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话带给大家
I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch life becomes about wins and losses
我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它，却仍然在追逐，我们不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们开始计较记分板，生活变成了赢和输
Steve Burns, Dustin Ross because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid because that's two different intentions bro absolutely and that's two different levels of trust I want you to just really be a good person Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way.
史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在世上做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人是因为你害怕？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟，绝对是的，这是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真的能做一个好人。加入我基尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，我们就疗愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标展开真实的对话。
Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for.
打开免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露出她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这拉开了长达数年的法律战的序幕，旨在证明真相。“你在某种程度上篡改了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？”“我篡改了一次测试。”这需要一支由互联网侦探组成的军队来破案。“我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用在了哪里。”
Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian and Michael Naranini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会揭开一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·莱斯皮安和迈克尔·纳拉尼尼。我的天哪。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这就是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. However you want to think about your 20s, whether this is a time to get serious about your future or a time for free. and the ability to make mistakes and chase emotional highs and maybe lows, I think that's something we can all agree is that they are not to be rushed and that taking time to know yourself and to know somebody else when you're dating and in a relationship before making huge decisions about your future
随着节季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有诈骗罪。在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。无论你如何看待你的20多岁，无论这是认真对待你未来的时候，还是自由自在、允许犯错、追逐情感高潮甚至低谷的时候，我认为我们都能达成共识的一点是，这些都不应该被匆忙对待，在对你的未来做出重大决定之前，花时间了解你自己，并在约会和恋爱时了解对方
is really important. I don't think that's a controversial thing to say. So my fourth red flag for this episode, if the other person wants an all or nothing relationship and wants it right away or just wants a relationship for the sake of a relationship so as pushing timelines, red flag, get out. Sometimes I think people like the idea of love more than the person that they think they are in love with. To them, a relationship is like a checkbox, right? Something that needs to be achieved in order to feel good about ourselves and to move on to the next life chapter or the next life stage. It just feels secure to be in a relationship and to be like, okay, yep, got that all tied down. These are, unfortunately, the people to avoid. Those who see their relationship with you
这真的很重要。我不认为这是一个有争议的说法。所以我的第四个警示信号是，如果对方想要一段非此即彼的感情，并且马上就要，或者只是为了谈恋爱而谈恋爱，从而在催促时间线，警示信号，快逃。有时我认为人们喜欢的是爱的概念，而不是他们自以为深爱的那个人。对他们来说，恋爱就像是一个复选框，对吧？为了对自己感觉良好并进入下一个人生章节或人生阶段而需要实现的事情。处于恋爱中并且觉得“好吧，搞定，这一切都尘埃落定”会让人感到安全。不幸的是，这些就是需要避开的人。那些把与你的感情看作
is no more than a commitment to maybe what the world expects of them, what they think they should be doing in their 20s where the world expects them to be by a certain age, you know, in love, living together, cat, dog, home ownership, all by the age of 30. And so they rush it. They rush it without respecting the need to get to know each other or the value of a slow burn or a slow manse. There's some people that is the path that they choose to take. So I don't necessarily think this is a red flag if you're on the same page about the pace of your relationship, right? Like if you're both in mutual agreement of like, yes, we are in love and obsessed with each other and like, let's move in. You know, I can't say if that's a mistake or not because it's up to you. And if you're both
仅仅是对世界对他们的期望的一种承诺，是他们认为自己在20多岁时应该做的事情，也就是世界期望他们在某个年龄达到某种状态，你知道的，谈恋爱、同居、养猫、养狗、拥有房产，所有这些都在30岁之前完成。所以他们匆忙行事。他们在不尊重相互了解的需求、不尊重慢慢培养或细水长流的价值的情况下匆忙行事。对某些人来说，那是他们选择的道路。所以我并不一定认为如果你对恋爱节奏的看法一致，这就是一个警示信号，对吧？就像如果你们双方都达成了共识，比如“是的，我们相爱并且对彼此着迷，让我们同居吧。”你知道，我无法说这是否是一个错误，因为这取决于你们自己。如果你们双方都
feeling that way, that's great. But I think you need to let that happen organically. and when it feels right, rather than feel like you're being rushed into something, rather than feeling like the commitment is happening faster than the getting to know you stage. So if this person is coming into the relationship, wanting everything all at once, I think there is probably some deeper psychological or subconscious motivation that is happening there. And maybe they don't even know it yet. Maybe it does have to do with their attachment style. Maybe it does have to do with past relationship hurt or trauma.
有这种感觉，那很好。但我认为你需要让这一切自然而然地发生，并且在感觉对的时候发生，而不是感觉自己被催促着进入某种状态，而不是感觉承诺的发展速度超过了互相了解的阶段。所以如果这个人进入感情时，想要一下子得到所有东西，我认为这背后可能存在一些更深层次的心理或潜意识动机。也许他们自己甚至都不知道。也许这确实与他们的依恋类型有关。也许这确实与过去感情中的伤害或创伤有关。
but it definitely needs further exploring. Here's why I think that this is a warning sign in my eyes, why it qualifies as a red flag. Firstly, it comes off as being very similar to love bombing. Love bombing, if you haven't listened to the episode that we did on this a little while back, it basically involves huge grand gestures and over-the-top displays of love and affection as an artificial way to speed up the relationship timeline and to really hook line and sinker you to really get you attached.
但这绝对需要进一步探索。这就是为什么我认为这是一个警告信号，为什么它符合警示信号的原因。首先，它看起来非常类似于爱的轰炸。如果你没有听过我们前段时间关于这个话题的那一集，爱的轰炸基本上包括巨大的盛大姿态以及过度夸张的爱意表达，作为一种人为加快恋爱时间线的方式，彻底让你死心塌地，让你深深依恋。
You know, saying that they love you after date too, moving in after date four, that kind of thing. And sometimes that promise of exclusivity and commitment can be really nice if you've been let down by a few duds or people who never give you what you want. But it can also be an indication of someone who is just addicted to the intensity of a relationship in those early days or who is trying to manipulate and control the situation or who is actually quite emotionally immature, has an anxious attachment style. So they're trying to lock you down ASAP. It's just something to be aware of. When we are in these situations, we sometimes lose who we are. It can become very controlling. It can disconnect you. And I think it doesn't leave much space for you to
你知道的，比如第二次约会后就说爱你，第四次约会就同居，诸如此类。有时候，如果你曾被几个渣男或从不给你想要的东西的人伤害过，这种对排他性和承诺的承诺会让人感觉非常好。但这也可以表明，某人只是沉瘾于早期关系中的强烈情感，或者试图操纵和控制局面，又或者实际上相当不够成熟，有焦虑型依恋风格。所以他们正试图尽快把你定下来。这只是需要注意的一点。当我们处于这些情况时，有时我们会失去自我。这会变得非常具有控制欲。它会让你与外界隔绝。我认为这没有留下太多空间让你
actually think through what you might want, not just from a relationship in your 20s, but what you might want from your future. So the other red flag or the other worry, that this red flag alerts me to is this kind of relationship that really burns way too bright. And the relationships that burn very bright burn very quickly. And we get very wrapped up in the promise and the extremes. And that can come crashing down. And I think if you have built everything around being with this person, if everything has just happened so quickly, it can be incredibly disruptive and shocking when suddenly that is over. So it's okay to just pause. And so, it's okay to just pause. slow down. You know, if they are the one, you will spend the rest of your life together.
真正思考你可能想要什么，不仅是你20多岁时的感情，还有你对未来的期望。所以另一个危险信号或另一个担忧是，这个危险信号向我发出了警报，即这种燃烧得太猛烈的关系。而且燃烧得非常猛烈的关系也会很快破灭。我们太过于执着于承诺和极端。这可能会轰然崩塌。我想，如果你所建立的一切都是为了和这个人在一起，如果一切都发生得太快，当这一切突然结束时，可能会带来难以想象的破坏和震惊。所以，暂停一下是没问题的。所以，暂停一下是没问题的。放慢脚步。你知道，如果他们是真命天子，你们会共度余生。
You know, if they are the one, don't worry about rushing it. The future is always going to be there. But if they cannot take no for an answer, if they cannot respect your timeline, I would say, get out. You know, I get it in our 30s or our 40s when some of those milestones have a bit more of a crunch period. Maybe we are better able to understand what we want. I get. Maybe the timelines being a bit more accelerated, but not in our 20s. Not in our 20s. Okay. Our final red flag for today.
你知道，如果他们是真命天子，就不要急于求成。未来永远都在。但如果他们对“不”字置之不理，如果他们不尊重你的时间表，我想说，离开吧。你知道，我理解在我们30多岁或40多岁时，一些人生里程碑面临更紧迫的时期。也许我们更能理解自己想要什么。我明白。也许时间表会稍微加快一些，但在20多岁时绝不能这样。绝不在20多岁时这样。好吧。我们今天的最后一个危险信号。
Number five, you just feel like different people. And from the beginning, you want them to change something fundamental or crucial about themselves. Now, this isn't a red flag in that it doesn't necessarily indicate that the other person is going to, I don't know, ruin your life. It's more of an orange flag that this relationship and this person isn't right. for you and ignoring that for too long, investing more and more time and energy into trying to make it work, into quote unquote fixing all these huge gaps in your personalities and your interests and
第五点，你觉得自己和对方是不同的人。从一开始，你就希望他们改变自身某种根本的或至关重要的东西。现在，这算不上危险信号，因为它不一定表明对方会，我不知道，毁了你的生活。这更像是一个橙色信号，表明这段感情和这个人并不适合你，而如果你忽视这一点太久，投入越来越多的时间和精力去试图让它行之有效，去所谓的修复你们性格、兴趣中所有这些巨大的鸿沟，以及
your values is eventually going to lead you nowhere and it may even lead to some regrets. Think about it in this way. You wouldn't want to be with somebody who had this small seed in the back of their heads at all time that they wanted to alter something about you. So I do think that it's a bit unfair to, it's unfair to everybody to pursue a relationship with somebody who is always going to create friction. There's always going to be a friction between what you expect from them and what they're actually able to give. Obviously, I think different is good. Different is new perspectives, different is new places, new beliefs, new opinions, new memories. And, you know, both, if you want to keep it casual and you want to learn from each other, go for it. But when it comes to like a serious
你们的价值观最终只会带你走向虚无，甚至可能导致一些遗憾。换个角度想想。你不会想和一个心里始终藏着一颗想要改变你身上某种东西的小种子的人在一起。所以我确实认为，对所有人都不公平的是，去追求一段与一个总是会产生摩擦的人的感情，这是不公平的。你对他们的期望与他们实际能够给予的之间，总是会存在摩擦。显然，我认为不同是好事。不同意味着新的视角、不同的新地方、新信仰、新观点、新记忆。而且，你知道，双方如果你想保持随性，想互相学习，那就去吧。但当谈到像严肃的
relationship like an I'm all in for you, you're all in for me kind of relationship. If there is a fundamental difference that feels like this bruise, a bruise on your partnership, a bruise on your connection that never goes away and that you keep, you know, pushing and prodding and it keeps stinging and flaring up and you just can never resolve it, maybe they are not the one and maybe you were better off being single for a little bit. I know that might be something that's hard to hear. in those situations when you are unsure and perhaps ignoring a real emotional and deeper psychological signal or clue from within that you need to move on, I do have a very deep belief
感情，比如那种“我为你付出全部，你为我付出全部”的感情。如果存在一种根本的差异，感觉就像这块淤青一样，是你伴侣关系中的淤青，是你连接上的永远不会消失的淤青，而你不断地，你知道，推它、戳它，它一直刺痛、发作，而你却永远无法解决它，也许他们不是你的真命天子，也许你单身一会儿会更好。我知道听到这些可能会很难受。在那些你不确定并可能忽视了内心真实情感和更深层心理信号或线索的情况下，你需要继续前进，我确实有非常坚定的信念
if you can't already tell that we are better off alone. 99% of the time during our 20s with 99% of the people that we come across, if we are given the option to stay single or to be in a relationship, you should stay single. Because anything a relationship can give you, you can give yourself those, you can give yourself those same things plus even greater realizations and an even greater dedication to your growth and into your identity and to your friends and to your goals. So the only person that I think worth, not so much on losing, but the only person worth switching from single to being in a relationship and perhaps losing out on some of those things, the only person that it's worth doing that for
如果你还看不出来，我们独自一人会更好。在我们20多岁的99%的时间里，面对我们遇到的99%的人，如果我们有选择单身或恋爱的权利，你应该保持单身。因为感情能给你的任何东西，你都可以给自己，你可以给自己同样的东西，甚至能带来更伟大的领悟，对成长、身份、朋友和目标的更大奉献。所以，我认为唯一值得的人，与其说是怕失去，不如说是唯一一个值得从单身转为恋爱并可能失去其中一些东西的人，唯一一个值得为此付出的人
is somebody who is pretty dang good and somebody who you are not 100% sure of because I don't think you can never be 100% sure, but who you are like really fascinated by and who is obviously providing you with a really safe and comfortable foundation to grow and who you aren't spending time being wanting to change, you know, who you aren't just in a relationship with for the sake of being in a relationship. If you were two to three, six months in and you're waiting for them to shift or change, I just don't think that that will ever happen. And there was a study done by Business Insider last year, which said, of all the reasons people break up that don't have to do with ghastly things like cheating or bad behaviours, the number one culprit is that they ignored
是一个相当不错的人，一个虽然你无法百分之百确定（因为我认为你永远无法百分之百确定），但你却真正为之着迷，并且显然为你提供了一个真正安全舒适的成长基础，而且你不会把时间花在想要改变他身上的人，你知道，你谈恋爱不是为了谈恋爱而谈恋爱。如果你在一起两到三个月或六个月了，还在等着他们转变或改变，我只是觉得这永远不会发生。去年《商业内幕》做过一项研究，其中指出，在所有与出轨或不良行为等可怕事情无关的分手原因中，排名第一的罪魁祸首是他们忽视了
their incompatibilities early on. You wanted kids, they never wanted them. You were a workaholic, they wanted a slow a lot, life, you know. He, she was really into drinking and partying, and that just wasn't who you were. It's an incompatibility that is the orange flag. You know, two, truly nice, lovely people can be in a relationship together and it could just not work out because they don't mesh in what they need from each other and they're kind of playing a tug of war. Are you going to change or am I? Who's going to shift here? That's what I'm a really amazing Dr. Susan South from Purdue University. She had to say about that. She called it a tug of war, a tug of war between two people who want to be themselves in a relationship but perhaps
他们早期的不合。你想要孩子，他们从来不想要。你是个工作狂，他们想要慢节奏的生活，你知道的。他/她非常喜欢喝酒和聚会，而那根本不是你。这种不合就是橙色信号。你知道，两个真正很好、很可爱的人可以谈恋爱，但可能就是无法长久，因为他们在彼此的需求上无法契合，他们有点像在拔河。你要变还是我要变？这里谁来做出改变？这就是普渡大学杰出的苏珊·索斯博士对这件事的看法。她称之为拔河，两个想要在感情中做自己的人之间的拔河，但也许
acknowledge that they might have to give up something they really care about to be with this person and questioning whether that's worth it, I don't think that it is. Relationships take up so much time and they're an investment, so please, please do not sink this valuable energy and space that you have in your life right now to something that doesn't feel right, especially during this period in our lives when there are so many situations and events and emotions, even the hard ones that we would get the privilege to experience solo and that we could really grow through. So I want to include some final lightning round red flags that are perhaps a bit more obvious for relationships in our 20s. Obviously there are some that are crucial no matter what,
承认他们为了和这个人在一起可能不得不放弃一些他们真正关心的东西，并质疑这是否值得，我不认为这值得。恋爱占据了大量时间，它们是一种投资，所以请千万、千万不要把生活中这些宝贵的精力和空间浪费在感觉不对的事情上，尤其是在我们人生的这个阶段，有这么多的情况、事件和情绪，甚至连那些艰难的情绪，我们都有特权独自去体验，并且能够通过它们真正成长。所以我想列举一些最后的闪电战危险信号，它们对于我们20多岁的感情来说可能更加明显。显然，有些是至关重要的，无论如何，
I think I said them before, but just to clear it up, you know, narcissism, abusive behavior, lying, all those things that we would typically think of there for every decade. But in our 20s, I think a lack of personal boundaries and not wanting to spend apart, that is a huge red flag. Make sure that you get the chance to be a free bird sometimes. You know, you don't get these years back. I think it's very similar to the first red flag. You still want to be yourself.
我想我之前说过，但为了澄清一下，你知道，自恋、虐待行为、说谎，所有这些我们通常认为存在于每个十年里的事情。但在我们20多岁的时候，我认为缺乏个人边界，不想分开，这是一个巨大的危险信号。确保你有时有机会成为一只自由鸟。你知道，这些年你是找不回来的。我认为这和第一个危险信号非常相似。你仍然想做你自己。
You still want to have things that are separate from them. I think it's really valuable. If they are extremely jealous and possessive, that is gross at any age, get out. If they are financially irresponsible and they go on to lie about it, or they want your help, run for the hills, run for hills. You know, sometimes people just aren't the best with money. Perhaps they didn't have the greatest financial literacy. That is not the same as being financially irresponsible and being completely, um, what's the word? Just completely dangerous about it or completely destructive about it and getting somebody that you care about involved, you know, I think they can recognize
你仍然想拥有属于自己的东西。我认为这真的很有价值。如果他们极其嫉妒和占有欲强，无论什么年纪这都很恶心，快离开。如果他们在财务上不负责任，并且还对此撒谎，或者想要你的帮助，快逃吧，快逃。你知道，有时人们只是不善于理财。也许他们的财商不是很高。这与在财务上不负责任并完全是，嗯，那个词怎么说来着？完全在这方面表现得很危险或完全具有破坏力，并把你关心的人卷进来，这不是一回事，你知道，我认为他们可以认识到
it as a problem and hopefully fix it. And I think the final thing to just remember is, are you on the same page about what you actually want. It doesn't matter how you choose to date in your 20s, whether you like casual dating, whether you like committed dating, whether you like polyamory, whether you like just sex. It doesn't matter. It's all up to you, but just remember, respect, communication, honesty and sincerity, but also that the other person is gentle and is just kind. That is a must. That is an absolute must. So thank you so much for listening to today's episode as we ran through some of the red flags, there may not have been some that you would think should make this list. Maybe I didn't include some that you thought were quite obvious. So if you
这是一个问题，并且有望解决它。我想最后要记住的一点是，你们在真正想要什么这一点上意见一致吗？无论你选择在20多岁时如何约会都无所谓，无论你喜欢随意的约会，还是认真的约会，还是喜欢多边恋，还是只喜欢性。这都无所谓。这全由你决定，但只要记住，尊重、沟通、诚实和真诚，以及对方是否温柔和善解人意。这是必须的。这绝对是必须的。非常感谢收听今天的节目，我们探讨了一些危险信号，可能有些信号你认为不应该出现在这个榜单上。也许我漏掉了你认为相当明显的一些。所以如果你
have some additional contributions, please feel free to DM me at That Psychology Podcasts and I'll share them on my Instagram because I feel like the more the merrier if there is something that you have learned from your experience dating in your 20s, whether that was committed or uncommitted. I would love to hear from you and make sure that you. you are following along wherever you are listening right now, Spotify, Apple Podcasts, wherever it is, make sure you never miss another episode. And if you did enjoy this episode, feel free to share it with a friend or leave a five-star review. And as always, until next time, stay safe, be kind, and of course, be gentle with yourself and look out for these red flags. For your own sake,
有一些额外的补充，请随时在 Instagram 上私信我 @ThatPsychologyPodcasts，我会在 Instagram 上分享它们，因为我觉得多多益善，如果你从20多岁约会的经历中学到了什么，无论是认真的还是不认真的。我很想听到你的声音，并确保你在你现在收听的任何地方都进行关注，无论是 Spotify、Apple Podcasts 还是其他平台，确保你不会错过任何一集。如果你确实喜欢这一集，请随时与朋友分享或留下五星好评。和往常一样，直到下次，注意安全，保持善良，当然，对自己温柔一点，并注意这些危险信号。为了你自己的好，
and we will talk soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs, And there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships,
我们很快就会谈到。2%。这就是走楼梯的人的比例，而且还有自动扶梯可用。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在这个奇怪的现代世界中展现精神坚韧、体能和建立韧性的标志。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，
and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO.% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target.
你就会破茧而出，成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。请在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。那是数字 2%。当一群女性发现她们都约会过同一个多产的骗子时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。
He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look at It, Putt at You, I got you. On the Look Back at it podcast.
他休想逃脱惩罚。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。听女朋友的话。相信我，宝贝，请在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back At It》播客中，
From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s.
从1979年开始，这对我和说是一段重要的时光。84年对我来说很重要。我是萨姆·杰伊。我是亚历克斯·英格利斯。每一集中，我们挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈80年代。
84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to Look Back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist
84年真是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。请在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back At It》。嘿，大家好，你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师
and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with.
兼主持人基尔·盖姆斯主持的《知难而进》。这个空间关乎黑男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，这些对话在其他任何地方进行其实都不安全，但你是在与一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲？它向世界发出信号，你是不好惹的。
And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, get your podcast. This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。请在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 获取播客上收听《知难而进》。这是一个 iHeart 播客。保证真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。